foreign
[Music]
okay yeah okay
God I hate them so much
[Music]
[__]
my guy just brought up a terrifying
point
he said
oh God this breaks my heart to even say
it says if they're not unlinking you
till tomorrow they'll they're gonna they
could try to take a cut of this podcast
they shouldn't [__] touch my Goddamn
money the membership money but it's just
one it could be today they try to steal
our money
that's crazy
that's crazy to me it's either take 30
of that I mean all of it gets reconciled
at the end of the month it might be fine
that's true because it's a monthly
evaluation yeah I think you're right you
know what they shouldn't be touching a
goddamn Penny yeah I mean that's the
reality of the situation but God damn
them dude